greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by Fuji Sports listen if I'm rolling
the only thing I wear is Fuji geese
that's it and the [ __ ] dash cards I
love them
the Fugees are tougher than that like I
said I'm down at 285 when I'm in
somebody's clothes going there tugging
on my [ __ ] collar they've tucked down
in the keys I've had before ripped Fuji
you all they get his fingerprints that
said that [ __ ] on rip so if
you're a big dude a 5 a 6 a 4 you're
looking for a great geek go over to Fuji
sports.com take a look at that great
selection whether it's just the the
purple one
the lightweight purple one that's like
99 bucks to the separator which is the
one I wear I love it 139 or something
like that it's tremendous it's lighter
than hell I got keys before that you
just got tired putting the thing on it
weigh 50 pounds this is like tough
dependable durable it's the way to go
for your big guy now I'm down a 5 and
I'm gonna assume being an a4 and I'll
still be in a fuji whether it's an
element a Seiko or a separate Oggy
they're my favorites they got matched
they got rash guards they got shame
guards they got everything but anyway go
to fuji sports.com right now I'm pressin
Church and get a 10% off delivered to
your house you help us out here number
two you know us it would taking
supplements I'm taking on it
salami was just here and I gave him a
shroom Tekken alpha brain he lives off
that [ __ ] he loves it why because it
works when the product says to you if it
doesn't work we'll give you your money
back and we don't even want the product
back you know you're working with
something that's alpha brain I go on my
little six six week cycles of alpha
brain I have a great time but listen
talk is cheap right go to go Hahnenkamm
right now go to supplements if you see
something you like the protein shake
it's not the hemp force anymore it's
Mexican chocolate I know that it's
[ __ ] delicious get the protein shake
for anyway go to Han come and press
enter BAM
and get 10% off your again delivered
right to your door kick this [ __ ]
with me only reading zero [ __ ]
it's Monday morning I want to talk to
you about something about 10 days ago I
got a call from Ari he was on a plane
and he was calling me to say goodbye
that he was going to Australia to do a
tour and he said that he might see me in
two weeks that he had a return ticket to
LA in two weeks
just in case Mitzi shore died and I go
what do you mean he goes here she's not
in good shape she's not doing well I
hung up the phone with him and I sat
down and and it was weird I haven't seen
Mitzi and maybe nine years you know ten
years or something I haven't seen Mitzi
but once he said that to me you know I
just started thinking at that whole
weekend now I was in Albuquerque with
Dean Dell we're at the Santa Ana casino
winter which is great people but just
the thought of what Mitzi meant to me
you know I got that that whole weekend I
thought about and just little things
about the store and stuff and last week
we did a podcast about you know people
will get misled they think that this is
just a [ __ ] catwalk this would
justify what I was saying last Sunday
and why I'm the way I had in 1995 I left
Colorado her name you know when I my
journey to be a comedian did I ever
think I would end up in that Lane not by
any means at all guys I thought I was
gonna be ham and Egger work like that a
Southwest the lorrison border of the
country and I was gonna hide that's what
I wanted to do I wanted to be a social
misfit and hide one thing turned to the
other ended up in Seattle one thing
turned to another I I got a call you
know over the holidays I went on stage a
couple days later the manager the club
called me the CBS was interested in me
so anyway back to the re thing he calls
me and he says this to me the whole
weekend I'm kind of thinking about my
life at the store and what it meant to
me you know and if you guys google it or
whatever there's probably a couple books
on the Comedy Store or stories about
myths ya know there's one book that's
some disgruntled person road
mentioned that they had had to go on a
strike to get paid from her and you know
ba-ba-ba-ba
this is my experience from that seashore
and what the Comedy Store meant to me
you know in 1995 I only read about The
Comedy Store like and Rudy Carla's book
and another books or comedy magazines
but in your mind when you first got into
comedy that was the Mecca Mecca for
Catholics it's going to Rome and seeing
the Vatican as a comedian Comedy Store
is it that's that's that's the mecca
that's the home of Kennison that's the
home of Richard Pryor that's the home of
Andrew Dice Clay that's a Roseanne was
seen that's where welcome back Carter
was written
that's what JJ walked I've been
discovered to be on good times I mean
the stories go on and on and on and on
about this place and what it attracted
over the years between you and I and we
and you know I never ever ever thought I
would walk into the chambers of the
Comedy Store that I would ever be good
enough so it didn't matter to me
whatever I heard like whatever the [ __ ]
everybody said to me I would just be
Joey Diaz taking it and blow it out and
go who gives a [ __ ] it doesn't matter
like people go I went to the comedy
store and you're like well you know they
let me in for free like oh who is a [ __ ]
or people going went down there and I
got on stage on open mic and who gives a
[ __ ] and what happened was when you're
working the rooms I was working at the
time you work the wit failed comedians
your work not really failed comedians
you're working with headliners who had
given la a try and it didn't work out
for them now that back home and they're
pissed at people who did stand something
was going on so you're also also heard
this negative undertone about Los
Angeles so it's like a sweet-and-sour
situation the whole time you're
developing as a comedian or at least for
me I wasn't developing to be on TV or
developing to be the next [ __ ] Richard
Pryor I was just doing comedy to see if
it would get me away
terminal aspect of my life I needed
purpose in my life I had tried
everything and comedy was the last
resort excuse me so I decided that if I
was gonna do comedy I was gonna commit
to it and I read everything I could
there was no internet there was no
computer and so you had to buy books and
read magazines and you know everything
that you read except like the Lenny
Bruce [ __ ] went back yeah I think even
the money Bruce stuff went back to the
county store so I'm living in Colorado
I'm having all these problems I'm
getting my car and I go to Seattle again
guys when I landed in Seattle in my
heart I wasn't good enough to be there
you know I had been for 20 years nothing
positive happen in my life nothing
nothing you know I got married now with
the prison [ __ ] like that but it still
was not what I was searching for I don't
know what the [ __ ] I was searching for
but none of that then it happened that
man at that point I was still waste
piece of [ __ ] in my mind I moved to see
how the Seattle that's what I started
making strides as a comedian and what do
I mean will you
we got MTV Joey you making money I was
making $800 a month on average and my
bills were like 18 hundred a month and
if it wasn't people like Carol I Josh
wolf who helped me out on I wouldn't
have made it you know but because I
committed to the journey the universe
takes care of you when you commit to a
journey the universe will take care
you'll find a way and even if you suffer
one night have to sleep out in the snow
six of those nights one way or another
you'll sleep on somebody's couch which
at that time is the rich commentator
the universe has a weird way of taking
care of you once it knows that you're
committed to what you're doing so I'm in
Seattle don't get arrested for this
stolen cause domestic rounds and I hear
it just didn't stop with my life and I'm
not gonna tell you that life was
throwing curveballs at me at the time I
was the [ __ ] problem I was the
problem between that the drugs you know
I didn't have control the only thing I
have control of was the comedy that's
the only thing I had definitely control
over was the amount that I got on stage
writing getting gigs hustling I was
dynamite at that stuff everything else I
was a [ __ ] failure on everything else
I was a failure
so what Thanksgiving I get on stage and
again the manager calls me are we
landing as listen some guy just call
from CBS they're doing a pilot and
you're perfect they coming up the second
week in December to bring the whole
staff to see that was [ __ ] rare guys
that was rare like Ferg a like me that's
a criminal and [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
kidding me did they see you somewhere or
what they said on me at the underground
the guy went home to visit his parents
for the holidays and the guy saw me on a
Wednesday night in the underground like
one of those holiday how many shows me
Josh wolf came the minuul Brody Stevens
Gavin boy it was like 10 of us that
would get together into a shell town
Hopkins the third you know and then we
get like a headlining to come in and we
do this show or the guy saw me and his
big question was if I spoke Spanish yes
then he brought like three people back
up there I got two things out of that
Club I pulled to LA things out of that
Club when they flew me into LA and I did
something I went back one time they flew
me in and I was so poor I cashed me the
ticket and I drove down there like an
[ __ ] that I had I pulled the way you
drove down here it's loaded the money
and went from Seattle yeah oh my god and
I went that Japanese restaurant ran
around the corner which is the worst
restaurant in the world or they sing on
the tables right yeah this is you
playing went there with two other
[ __ ] morons and but the first time I
came down I went to the last Factory I
didn't even think of going to economy
store didn't even think it's a Comedy
Store
and I didn't but you knew about it I
knew about
I knew at that time by 97 I hadn't read
the Kennison biography they talked all
about the power of the Comedy Store and
I'd seen something else or read
something else about Bill Hicks and
everybody's pads have across the Comedy
Store I knew that for one of his last
specials Richard Pryor works on the
Comedy Store and since I was from Denver
I also knew that Roseanne had done
something that no woman that I've ever
done she was a bit she became a paid
regular and which he saw in the original
room put her in the main room and then
she got The Tonight Show why she went
from being a [ __ ] slob to this thing
overnight really seriously that's crazy
and I know that yeah miss he saw and the
original rule told him to go up in the
main room and she got white and the next
night she was on The Tonight Show or two
days later or weeks later so I had
already known the power of the Comedy
Store but in my mind and I'd never be
good enough anyway and then all the
comedian's I spoke to those headliners
that didn't have anything going on that
were like angry headliners they were
putting down the Comedy Store like oh
you don't need to go up there there is
there yeah they're not gonna put you up
you gotta be this you gotta be that all
this [ __ ] I didn't listen because I
didn't care Lee it didn't matter
I was happy doing spots at the comedy
underground in Seattle would I give a
[ __ ] about the time he stole laughs
actually improv love me that was another
world it shows how important every set
is you can never look down on the set
you know and it's like a sense I said if
you're getting if you're getting stuff
for LA and see like that blows my mind
that someone in Seattle twice holidays
what the holidays to see their family
saw me onstage and the second one was
Jeff Valdez so the first year was Jeff
Valdez from Latino Comedy Festival and
they didn't give it to me that's he a
greg Giraldo became a start and then the
next year they approached me again for
channel I factor uh festival and CBS
approached me so I moved down here
I didn't think I'm moving down here CBS
is gonna give me enough money to get a
whole child for three weeks rent the car
and being able to go to there was no
Reuben and there was no you know and I
was gonna be able to go to rehearsal and
shoot the pilot only shams gonna be
three weeks that's a lot of money so I
came down here I lived in the trailer
with my girlfriend and it was the
weirdest thing because I had worked New
Year's would stand hope that New Year's
that wait the 27th through New Year's I
did like six shows with standoff and I
knew Doug from 1991 and Doug had seen me
then and now Doug was watching me
featuring form and he kept bugging me
you need to move to LA you really do
need to move that light they have Latino
night on Sunday night at the improv they
got one at the Comedy Store they got one
at the Laugh Factory not only that
you'll get spots anyway keen I'm like
but what about what everybody else is
saying they're saying you can't get
spots it's like [ __ ] those losers you
get spots and I'm like yeah but I'm
dirty [ __ ] it don't worry about it
you'll get spots so between Doug
Stanhope in my here is the CBS thing I
agree to the CBS thing and I drove down
here with a girl to the trailer with a
car behind us and the trailer broke in
San Francisco and we've spent seven five
days in San Francisco and I got onstage
every day in San Francisco so it didn't
really matter
well we headed I'm landing here on a
Monday we came into LA when we saw LA
the 101 south I can't describe the
feeling that you like I can't describe
the feeling feeling we was still an hour
out we were in bumper-to-bumper traffic
and then we pulled off we got into
Hollywood we down to the Sunset Strip
and on Fairview Fairfax Boulevard we
made it right and we pulled our trailer
right there when you go up to Laurel
Canyon and make the left
right then we pulled up and we loosened
up a car and we both took showers in the
trailer we got dressed and we went to
where you're going tomorrow night what's
that I'm gonna place you're going
tomorrow night
oh the Sycamore tavern that used to be
alcohol in 1997 and we went to have for
dinner we thought it was like [ __ ]
the restaurant of the year if I had $300
on me a lot of money really I had no
money when I moved out here
what was it for that girl driving the
whole [ __ ] thing I would've never got
down here
like can you explain like I want to go
back and just a little bit to what you
said about the sign for the 101 like
what do you think do you think you
finally started believing in yourself or
what do you think happened when I saw
the sign I realized that this was real I
started doing comedy in 1991 but for two
years it was throwaway years I was I
wasn't even doing comedy I was doing an
impersonation of an impersonation was
impersonation and then I understood what
it took to become a comedian so I had to
yeah I've been doing comedy for 27 years
but it's really 25 years because my
first two years I got onstage like eight
times
I was just bullshitting people
bullshitting myself but I really can't
say that because the second year I had a
job I had a job a house and scene I got
on stage every week but I still wasn't
serious about it I was just blowing
smoke up my ass I was just addicted to
coke once 94-95 came along I got serious
about it and by 95 I was very serious
about it like I was down I was in this
is what I wanted to do I don't know I'm
not saying I'm gonna be the next [ __ ]
Richard Pryor the next Sam Kinison all
I'm saying is that for right now this is
what I want to do I wasn't gonna give
myself high hopes and then be let down
like I'm gonna be on t I knew I was
never gonna be a TV I'm not an act
even though you're coming down for a TV
show even that by that time I was like
this is crazy as soon as I get Tali I
gotta find that acting coach and I
remember actually asking the executive
producers of the show like do you guys
can you rang you know how's that little
half a [ __ ] like you guys recommend an
acting coach the work of me before I
shoot the pilot and they're like oh yes
we have brilliant acting coaches you
know so as soon as I got here on a
Monday and what the hell Caputo I
changed to the shower we went to the
Acapulco or you could eat and I headed
up to the Comedy Store I don't know what
possessed me I took that girl we walked
into the Comedy Store and they stopped
me in the front that I said I'm a comic
and they said okay at that in those days
there was no really a lot of security
Monday nights it was either Harris Peter
Chewie and I walked around the back and
they let me sit and then it Don Barris
was on stage the first time I was I was
walking into the comedy store I saw the
star of the Last Dragon and Eddie
Griffin walking out and I shouldn't have
been like I had seen Eddie Griffin and a
Bruce Willis movie and I had sort of
seen him on some me they'll be here HBO
or something he was hilarious and here
he was in front of me at the place where
you're gone and I walk in there's the
halls and all the pictures of these
great comics and I'm just shaking my
[ __ ] head going I don't even know why
I'm here and then there was a comment
from Seattle James Stevenson third it
was open mic night if there was 15
people in the audience there was a lot
of people it was real real audience yeah
it was 8:30 at night there's 15 people
you know it and down virus is up on
stage like there was [ __ ] masses my
god with shorts on [ __ ] crazier than
ever and I'm like what the [ __ ] is this
and then as i sat there comics came in
and out who I kind of knew
I could travel II heard their names but
then as it got later that's when Eddie
Griffin showed up and Nick DiPaolo and
ours Justin [ __ ] law like I didn't
walk in the kitchen nothing I just stood
out in the hallway and then I met wheels
wheels Parisi yeah he came was there
like a you opened for dice oh my god I
that was [ __ ] complete all and I
spoke to him for a little while and the
waitresses in Philadelphia and the name
was Eleanor who have had on the podcast
here various times she was the waitress
from Philly to us when they told me to
go see her and she gave me like the
water or whatever the [ __ ] they gave me
in those days a solar they tipped her
and that's all I know that was it and I
stayed out there till 12:00 12:30 just
talking to different comedians and at
one time they ran out of comics and this
isn't a man do you want to go up as it
was an open mic oh yeah and I walked up
there there was maybe three people in
the audience poor people on it and I
just went up there what that's the stage
of my feet I said this is hilarious that
I'm gonna be able to put the time least
all my resume and now really do is show
you but basically a hand over the show I
had three minutes and everyone else told
all those negative people told you it's
impossible to get on your first time
there at the Comedy Store do you want to
go so I got on there was nobody in the
audience I hate a bag of dicks but a
couple comics came in and watched me and
they were like you should but the weird
thing was that every year since 1995 or
1994 to 1997 so I walked into the Comedy
Store now that night that I walked into
the county store is January 29th 1997 so
listen to these dates
correctly and I landed on a Monday but
the funny thing about this was that for
once a month somebody would come up to
me and look at me and you know it's
Mitzi sure seeing you yet then I go what
what the [ __ ] is Mitzi sure and let's
say that's paulie's mother wait till she
sees your dog I'm like I'm she's never
gonna see me guess I'm never walking in
there like I'm never walking in there
but all directions were pushing me into
the store there was a contest in Denver
in 1995 and the winner got 500 cash and
he got a a plane ticket hotel a spot in
front of Mitzi shore holy [ __ ] she's
basically a Monday night spot and you
weren't guaranteed she was gonna be
there it's just a [ __ ] contest
oh [ __ ] and I came in a second but back
nan Chu is that well respected she was
worked out well-respected
do you get to perform in front of mid
sea shore that's pretty crazy and that
night I came in second but the next day
comedians called up the club and said
the guy who won the contest stole the
jokes so they had to give me the 500 I
never got that quaint sake I didn't go I
never got it from the club they banned
me for life before I got it that sucks
yes so all directions were always
pointed to me to go into the comedy
store so the first week I go to the
comedy store girl on stage that first
night I go holy [ __ ] in my mind I was
just happy to get on stage at the Comedy
Store I could have told anything to
anybody I could have said to you Louie I
went up there there was 200 people might
kill in the original room yeah and I had
to bring up Jim Carrey it wasn't the
case there was three people and then I
brought some comic Upton a harmonica or
some [ __ ] you know it wasn't like the
show show show yes it was in the
original room and yes it was the
world-famous Comedy Store but I didn't
go up late o'clock at night Tina
Mazzanti
oh I know exactly I could have went back
to Jersey or back the
and were and told you anything I wanted
right I perform there Mitch he sure
loved me no there was nobody there
but I went home that night and I felt
different well I felt different him away
like stronger like if you did decently
well I would feel like you'd have a huge
power of work no I didn't have a boner
over it but it have a yeah I felt like I
don't know like I maybe maybe maybe
someday in 10 to 15 years I can tell
economy store that's what I felt and
that was it and the story that was it
the next Tuesday morning I got up and I
went to the Laugh Factory and I still
online at 7:00 in the morning and like
and then made me wait there from 7:00 in
the morning to 6 o'clock at night oh and
me and Gavin alternated and we would
cross the street and get each other
juices and [ __ ] and Wohlers and
sandwiches but we were standing on you
understand online all day [ __ ] the next
week right no for just one day ok so
that was every Tuesday Tata
every Tuesday if you drove past the
Laugh Factory you see 20 people standing
up that they don't do it anymore like
that oh I thought they did I don't know
I don't know if they still do it like
that so the next one I got a bright-eyed
and bushy-tailed when went down there I
went online all day and I heard all
these [ __ ] comedians just talking how
hard it is what a waste of time they've
been doing that they auditioned for
Spielberg and then get the movie that
auditions are hard that it's tough to
get an agent it was just 20 19 people
talking [ __ ] negative just just
garbage like if you're here he'll never
make your regular we're just wasting our
time but just just it was just dumb
[ __ ] chatter and there was one guy in
particular who wouldn't shut the [ __ ] up
but he had a weird accent he wouldn't
shut the [ __ ] up he knew everything
about everything
he was an encyclopedia [ __ ] commie he
knew what time it's he sure got there
what time is he sure left when to go to
the improv
when Mudd Friedman was gonna be there to
pass you he knew everything Lee and then
we got our numbers at six o'clock eight
o'clock came it was time for me to go on
stage and the guy went up there and not
only did he eat the biggest bag of dicks
I ever seen some leave but he went from
being this loud obnoxious guy like me
talking like a little [ __ ] mouse and
when he got off I looked him right in
the face I go all day all [ __ ] day
you talk to all that [ __ ] all [ __ ]
day and you got on stays like a [ __ ]
hermit
I thought he thought we were gonna
fistfight that's how crazy Esther was
that is absolutely I might say you
listen to him although all [ __ ] day
he didn't shut the [ __ ] up but then he
goes up then he becomes Joe Herman
anyway I'm the main on the list I go up
there I'd do my dirty material you gotta
wait around to get critique from Jamie
and as soon as I sat down Jamie goes
listen I'm gonna give you the best
advice I can give you pack your bag
learn more Las Vegas I think what are
you talking about he was your club comic
because if you move to Las Vegas and
starting old right now and five years
everybody will know who you are but
you're not gonna do anything in LA
you're too old you're too dirty you're
never gonna do nothing here you can't
pass this up I was like Jesus Christ
this is crazy this is crazy so I said
you know what it doesn't matter cuz I'm
just gonna shoot the pilot and go back
to Colorado and try to be a dad or in
the chillness woman you know I had no
options I had no real options so I woke
up the next morning and I went to uh I
think it's 65 65 Sunset Boulevard
something like that and they have
telemarketing jobs like three or four
floors of different tell
in job right there and it's all
automated so I walked in there and I had
done telemarketing before but never
automated where you make 80 calls now
it's just constant you know I'm saying
like this is you're gonna hang up it's
constant how was it you say that the
building is still there and they still
did something wrong it's a beautiful
building on Sunset they redid it but on
the walk home I bumped into his blank
dude and we were just talking
generalities and he told me he was a
manager and it's our marketing world
where people making eight to fifteen
hundred a week selling cigars on the
phone and that was all more money than
you were making there was a lot more
money that I had made in [ __ ] three
or four years like I was making no money
and I didn't make a dime in 95 96 97 oh
now they would give me money to move
down here but by that time I owed money
I hold back child support I owned a
thousand things I bought some coke to
buy some clothes so that money
disappeared so me and the girl got into
a fight not only gymnast out of [ __ ]
tell me I sucked but the girl told me
out of a [ __ ] cop sanaya little it
would Doug Stanhope on the top bunk
he walked bad bunk beds of his
appointment because he was dating a girl
from a TV show that so he would never
spend the night at his house so he had a
bedroom and he had bunk beds in his
living room with a TV and a typewriter
out there so if you want to write Joshi
to write jokes if you want to sleep you
can sleep so at that time it was me and
one of his [ __ ] friends that was just
out of his mind named ron ron was on the
Doug Stanhope gonna be a star but it was
done security he was done he played like
bunk security but he was just a big guy
you know he didn't know nothing about
nothing you know at that time 1997 Doug
Stanhope we made a big bag of Hollywood
and Here I am living with Doug and I'm
selling a gauze in the [ __ ]
they thought I come waking up in the
mornings at 6:00
no no they and I would sell cigars like
from [ __ ] Senate him one morning to
[ __ ] 12:00 or 1:00 in the afternoon
every day it was rough and I started me
and Josh wolf we would go to a place you
don't bar him right yeah burbank there
there was an open mic there every night
there was a coffee shop you know where
what's the taco place don't we go to
over there cactus cactus across the
street from the cactus whether the
children's is a place there with
children's play I didn't know that used
to be a coffee shop and that was a big
time open during the day at night okay
it was a coffee shop all day but at
night it became a comedy room oh okay
so there was a steak place in the valley
the Sutton Steakhouse up in the valley
and they had a back room and they do
calmly so for those you know for my
first two weeks here I did what you're
doing now here I started from scratch
like I had already been insulted by
[ __ ] what's his name but Sunday
nights was Latino night at the improv
cuz I got a hold of that guy and he said
I'll give you your five minute guess set
and he goes I want you to come back next
three well why don't you wear a tuxedo
or a suit his name was John Mercedes why
didn't you want you to wear a suit
because he said he didn't mind if I
worked dirty as long as I wore a suit so
John Mercedes would basically put me on
stage on Sundays at the improv and I'm I
told you people say you're not gonna get
on stains in this town and you're at
sort of the thing so already I'm at the
improv on a Sunday night and I'm here
about two weeks I got a job selling
cigars Josh wolf is living on Vista
Ralphie may wasn't here yet at this time
Ralphie May was not here I was sleeping
on Stan Holmes couch on his bunk bed
Ron was on the bottom bunk men
and at night we just got together
whoever you just got together like when
you do with Shawn and for and we were
just go from open mic to open mic
smoking pot you know one place gave me a
drink ticket but there was this cat
named Rudy Marino who I had on the show
years ago and he booked a room on
Fridays and Saturday it's called a brave
bull and everybody said you gotta get on
stays down there but [ __ ] Rudy I
called Rudy 80 times bro I called him
every day spoke Spanish you never call
me back so on Friday I got directions I
got in the car and I [ __ ] went down
it
Alessa who's Rudy Moreno they go that
guy and I walked out already when I'm
Jody is why you can't call me back
I think it's like I'm sorry I'm busy I
can give you five minutes this [ __ ] and
I went up there and became friends of
ruiny so now I was already doing spots
on the weekend Rudy told me come back
next week and I was twenty five dollars
a spot that's 50 [ __ ] bucks guys 50
bucks and those days guys you have no
idea what I do or 15 bucks in those days
you had no idea in cash in cash so in
this time I realized CBS doesn't know
what they're gonna do CBS doesn't know
if they're gonna shoot me for the pilot
or save me for a seven episodes
[Music]
or you were jumping on being on the show
yeah definitely I'm the show I'm a
crucial part of this show you feel like
everything is coming together I didn't
really know I didn't know what was going
on it's not my work this is not my world
okay I had already found I was already
buying coke in the building I knew where
to buy coke already like at that time
job Josh wolf brothers friend in the
building sold coke so we were already
getting coke I'm here about two weeks
two and a half weeks and I'm already
getting on stage at the improv and I'm
already getting on stage whatever but
the first time I came to the showcase
from latina laughs festival I met a girl
there a woman who looked kind of like
you 5 foot 2 300 pounds
she just had like a [ __ ] shower
curtain over as a dress why she was just
a little short fat little Mexican check
but the name was Marilyn Martinez and
she watched me go up and she said hey
man admits he was in yeah yeah like what
would you stop with that seeing his arm
and she's gonna [ __ ] love you man so
I'm talking with Doug staying home one
day and like leave and I gotta do an
open mic and who do I bump into but
Marilyn and she goes did you move here
and I go yes she goes did you put
yourself on the showcase list for mitzi
yet I don't know I don't know if I'm
gonna stay here I'm here shooting a
pilot a bar she goes listen I'm gonna
call Scott day tomorrow Scott day was
the talent cornet she knows I'm a
regular that I'm gonna get you a
showcase spot there
I didn't know what to say I just told
you that the universe takes care of all
of you and they know you're committed to
what you're doing I didn't know what to
say at this point in my life guys I'm
dirty [ __ ] four years old 33 years
old I was in prison I just you guys have
no idea what I was going through at that
time and Here I am becoming this
comedian and here I get this deal from
CBS and they gave me a little bit of
money and then one of those Latino
nights a little bald guy comes up to me
and he goes I don't
my name is ba ba ba ba ba pop and I'm an
agent his son Bart Ehrman awry we do
commercials do you have a commercial
audition agent I don't know I think
those we do I decide where somebody yeah
I don't know nothin about nothin' guys
absolutely I do the next day I find out
Sutton Bart Ehrman re at the time was
the best commercial agent in the [ __ ]
Lake
oh [ __ ] like I just signed with the best
commercial agent in the [ __ ] lamp
like getting here and signing with I'm
like what the [ __ ] am i talkin about he
goes yeah we're gonna get ya for
commercials and voiceovers I wanted to
do contract and then John Mercedes
introduced me to a dude introduced me to
a dude there was a manager and he was
carrot tops manager for wanna goes you
want to talk to him well yeah he goes he
wants to talk because you're a carrot
that we talked for a few weeks but in
this whole time that night I see Marilyn
and Marilyn tells me this all goes done
at the improv but Marilyn tells me that
she's there for a Tina night that she's
gonna get up tomorrow morning and call
Scott day
so I go home floatin on [ __ ] you know
clouds but in the back of my mind it
really doesn't matter because people
showcase for her all the time she gets
off on turning people down every it
seems like a lot of people have stories
about taking a long time for ya ya pass
so I'm like even if I showcase it
doesn't matter because I'm not gonna
stay like this is just a [ __ ]
vacation for a few weeks I'm a [ __ ]
father I gotta go back to Colorado try
to [ __ ] see my kid and go to war with
this [ __ ] even though I'm [ __ ] poor
I'm living in Carla whatever the [ __ ]
I'm standing on dad Doug Stanhope
[ __ ] couch whatever the [ __ ] I was
doing at that time that next morning
when I wake up it's Monday morning and I
got a little cigar job when I come back
Doug Stanhope is in the living room he's
typing he's talking a fat runt
God rest his soul and that's when he
says to me hey man I called Scott day
today Isis glad they got two calls two
calls because I called Scott daily and
told him to make you a regular at the
store for you to show cash you need a
regular to Matthew he goes to call him
up during the week call him up later on
during the week and he'll schedule for a
showcase so right now I got the greatest
comic in the land and Madeline Martina
has calling Scott day I never met Scott
day I don't know what the [ __ ] got day
looks like I don't know nothing
now the next one guys is really gonna
throw you for a [ __ ] loop I go to a
show at The Improv on a Wednesday night
and who do I bump into right after that
whole thing on Monday with Marilyn and
now at this time I've got my first spot
at the improv the talent coordinator
Richard Cooper his window used to be you
could see the window still he would sit
there at night with the window open and
watch you and he watched me Latino night
and he
came down and told me to call if the
spots there in a week so I wasn't doing
too bad I'm not gonna tell you I was
struggling no I was struggling I'm
really was struggling but [ __ ] I'm here
three weeks I'm getting spots at the
improv I got a commercial agent I got a
job that makes OK money
I'm snort little coke me and the girl
are on the rocks
me and my daughter on the rocks me and
my ex-wife are on the right I mean my
everything around me was [ __ ] except
this comedy [ __ ] there except this
[ __ ] comedy thing which was the
biggest long shot in the [ __ ] world
for a guy like me guess who I bump into
the improv that night on the Wednesday
night guys when I go down there too but
a year ago I put somebody on the podcast
and I got questioned by everybody
I got questioned by so many [ __ ]
people on my decision why I put this
kind of the podcast and you're gonna
realize why I put him on the podcast
when I tell you who I bumped into guess
who I bumped into it and I think it can
I guess yes Carlos Carlos Mencia and he
came up to me and he gave me a hug and
he goes how long have you been in town I
told him three weeks I'm trying to be a
regular at the store and he goes you
know what I'll call Scott day for you
tomorrow now you understand why I put
Carlos on the podcast because before I
thought that Carlos was a fee for
anything this was way before I met Joe
wrote three people vouch for me at the
Comedy Store
all right so now it's Thursday and my
pager goes off and it's three two three
number six five six I call it back and
it's the Comedy Store I go this is joke
did somebody call me from The Comedy
Store like hold on one second and the
phone picks up and it's got Danny Gus
Joey Diaz yes Scott day now he was a
write off
right off the bat like that first
conversation it wasn't like it didn't
mean the world to me like it was like
Joey Diaz yes Scott day Town coordinate
I've had a few people call in here for
you I'm gonna put you on the showcase
list but the bad news isn't it takes six
months
there's that many people who want a
showcase from it so yeah it's a
six-month waiting list five so what do I
go I go thank you very much you know
thanks for calling me and he goes yes
well it's February you'll be hearing
from us like in [ __ ] September and
more what part of you is upset or were
you just thinking this is gonna be upset
no no no parts of me upset because right
now that gives me six months to prepare
that's sure that gives me 6 months to
[ __ ] prepare for the killer a killer
so I'm gonna finish this [ __ ] pilot
I'm gonna take whatever money they have
to me whatever they're gonna give me
like figure then we're gonna give me
scale for two days at the end of
shooting three days there's $2,100 or
something like that and I was gonna go
back to Colorado and start a new life
this is right there Thursday 2:00 in the
afternoon I'm shooting the following
[ __ ] Monday Tuesday and Wednesday and
I'm gonna leave here with a showcase for
Mitzi shore and [ __ ] September I got
six months to work on whatever the
minute she wants I don't even know how
many minutes she wants okay I hang up
with Scott day and about three hours
later I get a [ __ ] call from the
pilot people and they go listen you're
shooting tomorrow one scene for the
pilot and then you're done you call time
is 9:15 CBS Radford I knew nothing wait
I knew [ __ ] nothing
you've been to here three weeks you know
what I know nothing they gave me a zip
code at that time in a [ __ ] street
number and I asked around and thank god
Josh wolf had been here like two months
before me he went on meetings he told me
where to go I think it was Josh who
drove me like somebody had to blend me
their car or something like that
[ __ ] I got a ride from somebody and then
I took like a bus back but I went up
there at 8:00 in the morning they did
did the fitting that day and basically
dog my role like after they saw me and
looked at me and talked to me like they
[ __ ] hated me but they had spent the
money on me already
now they put me in the show like when I
read for it and rehearse with them
I have like two scripts but I was so bad
of an actor or so such as piece of [ __ ]
that I was that dad cut me down the two
lines Lee in the pilot like what are you
having Nick the usual a beer on ice
hahaha and I giggle or something stupid
like two cops come in when I first got
the script it was two cops come in and
then I asked him that [ __ ] and then we
go to like a monologue a piece like
listen we all know what this is we pay
you every week you let us know who comes
in he and gives us the information so I
was playing like a bartender type rat to
prosecutors and it wasn't going well
when I got the script I had a [ __ ]
huge role of this right but have to
rehearse him with them two or three
times they saw I wasn't a [ __ ] actor
but I was green like a [ __ ] like
a Bailey I knew nothing my guys I knew
nothing and at that time I hunted around
and I found the guy on a Monday who
coached me on that and I liked them his
friend his name was Frank magnet look at
that I still remember his name he
coached me for a twenty bucks an hour
and I went down and I still stuck like I
I just start guys oh you want me to lie
to you and tell you I was Olivier I
still stink as an actor I just use
stand-up as my backup but I'm no actor
so I'm not ashamed to telling you people
this story cuz I never really told you
this story when I got the pilot when I
first got the script I had two or three
pages of monologue on one scene and two
pages of monologue on another I
rehearsed it with them they went back
and forth I didn't know [ __ ] I think I'm
one of the rehearsals I was high from
the night before
so when I got to the pilot they just
everything shut me down the two lines I
went up the CBS Radford I find that
right where it was I went up there I did
the costume fitting they hated me so
much they shot me out
first Jesus all right I was just
thinking about this like that I didn't
remember the whole story until last week
what I really really thought about what
really [ __ ] happened I think I made
up a lie just to tell I don't know what
I did but that's what really happened by
the time I shot
they were like you done I got out of
there all right
I took a bus back to Hollywood okay and
I remember I did the paperwork and I
asked the lady do I get paid today and
she's like no you get paid in ten to 14
days so I'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] now I gotta
wait two more weeks and sleep on Doug
Stanhope Doug Stanhope wasn't mad at me
or anything I just didn't want to be
here and that's it I'm getting the
showcases six months I did my spots I'm
a regular at The Improv when I come back
with Tina and I will be bigger than ever
and this is how it'll work out my pager
goes off it's about 5:30 in the
afternoon and I'm standing in Doug
Stanhope living room by myself my pager
goes off it's the Commish store but I
call him back I know this is Joe Diaz
it's somebody calling like here hold on
Scott dance God dang goes Joey are you
available this Sunday to showcase for
Mitzi shore and I go when you said six
months and he goes no no no no I had two
or three fall outs can you can you do it
this Sunday and I go yeah I'll be there
and that was it when I hung up the phone
and it was that easy I wasn't even here
a month and I was showcasing for Missy
show no no for [ __ ] in seven years
I heard nothing but negativity nothing
but negativity right nothing you'll
never get on
bah-bah-bah-bah-bah-bah right then and
there the [ __ ] hanging up that phone
and just going what the [ __ ] is going on
it but right then and there I thought
about what I had been going through all
those years and how I was doing comedy
through it like I had the worst that I
have a guy I still pushed and I still
kept like no I can't tell you how bad I
was feeling when I would drop that
little girl off on Wednesdays it said I
can never describe to you how bad I
would feel we're attached to another man
with my ex-wife
well I would immediately get in my car
and force myself to do comedy and turn
that anger and rage into funniness to
cover me at least for an hour to make me
feel good like that's what that showcase
meant to me like I was like okay all
that [ __ ] ain't off with you the only
reason you were leaving LA then before
this phone call was to go back to your
daughter in Colorado was I was gonna go
home but just who the [ __ ] was I oh my
kids you said everything was going so
well don't let it did matter I was gonna
[ __ ] it up I was gonna [ __ ] it up
somewhere I already [ __ ] it up Lee I
just [ __ ] it up instead of getting the
[ __ ] acting coach when I got down
here and working with him for three days
in a row I stood on line and I talked to
people at coffee shops instead of
getting an acting coach like I was
supposed to do
I didn't do that I got him for one
afternoon and then when they're acting
like [ __ ] da Vinci and I hit lit up
blowing it you know I'm saying it
doesn't matter today but it mattered
them what was going on in my life like I
felt shittier and shittier now you're
trying to tell me I got a showcase this
[ __ ] lady on Sunday so what are the
odds of me getting past with all the bad
[ __ ] that's happening so I'm like wait a
second they didn't wait me on the pilot
so this guy at the Laugh Factory told me
I was basically a [ __ ] ham a bum The
Improv the guy must be drinking you know
the guy must be [ __ ] him he must feel
good for handicapped kids or something
why am I getting spots went for seven
years all I heard was negativity all I
heard was [ __ ] negativity why would
she give me a [ __ ] spot why would she
give me a [ __ ] showcase so I hung up
that [ __ ] phone with Doug Stanhope
and I went everywhere I'm gonna live
without there was an open mic like on
Santa Monica towards the 101 like that's
a bad neighborhood back there I still
remember going there and standing in the
back of the room and just going onstage
and bombing that night in front of a
bunch of comics going how am I gonna
[ __ ] pass in front of Mitzi shore
but like you were preparing for the the
show yeah oh yeah I [ __ ] stayed up
one night sober and wrote I [ __ ] got
my best three minutes together that I
ever have ever had I polished them
backwards I knew the material backwards
and forward you had three minutes and
three [ __ ] minutes that's not a lot
like it sounds like a lot of time when
people say oh you do a five minute open
mic when you've never done one before it
sounds scary but three minutes is not
that much time three [ __ ] minutes I
had in front of the lady who [ __ ]
could call your life right now with one
[ __ ] this is you know going up in front
of mitzi is like [ __ ] meeting Carly
and being on my world
like that's what it was that like not
only am I gonna get to meet her but I'm
gonna go up in front of her and she's
gonna turn me down anyway and now I'm
really gonna be [ __ ] crushed I was
gonna say was the where do you imagine
what what happened I was gonna get
knocked down but I said [ __ ] it if I go
down let me go down in flames so I did
every open mic I [ __ ] couldn't have
for every fourth wall that you guys know
locally I [ __ ] didn't those two days
when I went in there Sunday night at 7
o'clock I was prepared I was [ __ ] a
pickle I wore like a dress shirt and I
wore my jeans I wore my sneakers you
know I was 33 years old and I was about
to put everything on the [ __ ] line
like this was gonna be the decisive
moment in my life and guess what I
walked up there with zero confidence
what are you after all those upper ranks
Lee you have no idea what the clown is
not represented at that time for a comic
of my caliber this is the White House
this is it if you don't say him like
this was everything I have like this was
and Here I am doing Tommy on paper six
years I'm like this isn't [ __ ]
happening
this
happening I don't have a manager I don't
you know this isn't happily but I still
want data and I remember I was scared
shitless I went down there with this
girlfriend of mine and one of my friends
from Seattle and I was scared shitless
I think Josh wolf was came down there
with me and I sat I walked up and when I
walked up she was sitting there already
and we made eye contact and she smiled
and I smiled when I sat down and you
know I know been known to be a kiss-ass
like that or anything I just sat down on
the corner and then I went up to
bootless and my name is Joey Diaz they
pointed me in the direction of the host
I think the host that night was Freddie
soul or God rest his soul I went up to
Freddie and Hill Freddie I'm Joey Diaz
and Merrill was there well they came to
watch for yourself
Bella was dead Doug Stanhope was there
and they all came down there and I was
pacing I was nervous I was like number
am I on the list yeah thank God you
weren't first
yes um it was something crazy like
something crazy
and I still remember them going you're
next and like you know your whole life
like a pop I saw myself in prison I saw
my mother's grave right I thought about
me getting in GD I thought about me
[ __ ] dropped out of high school I
thought I just thought about every
negative thing that could happen in my
life like nothing positive came into my
mind at that moment like nothing nothing
really like nothing I'm gonna go up
there and do this she's gonna tell me to
go [ __ ] myself and I'm gonna go back to
Stanhope's wait for my check and go back
to Colorado and just do local comedy do
[ __ ] radio gigs this [ __ ] like that I
already had an escape plan
I went up there and as I was getting
ready to go on stage Eddie Griffin came
and set him next to her now the night I
will not stay is that Monday night when
I first came to town I bumped into Eddie
Griffin but Eddie Griffin didn't leave
he was in the back of the room talking
loud while I was on stage but he watched
me someone Eddie Griffin saw me
showcasing for midsi he sat next to
Mitzi and he didn't really let anybody
talk to Mitzi cuz that's the secret god
rest her soul of showcase infancy was
surrounding her so nobody could talk to
her while you were on stage she would
not pass you she didn't see you but she
wouldn't make she wouldn't like she
wouldn't stop people from interrupting
her she would talk to the dog everybody
wanted to kiss her ring everybody wanted
to kiss her ring so soon as she said
that edge chair everybody would come in
her direction
waitresses managers comics future comics
open my kurz I mean [ __ ] everybody me
she was like Dana White like she was
that powerful she could change your life
it was like that contest like the
ultimate fighter even saying it was like
that like she's the [ __ ] host of The
Ultimate Fighter and I went up there and
I mentioned something about being cubed
and I did okay Lee I guess and when I
walked past as she grabbed my hand and
she smiled and she goes can you come
back next week and do ten minutes oh my
god and I go yes and she goes you were
very funny or something like that and
that was their problem like I was like
oh my god and then people were like wow
that's what she loves to do make you
come back and then tell you no so now I
had to live another week of torturing
yourself torture myself and doubting
myself that I was a neat [ __ ] but again
I went
every night and I did a [ __ ] spot and
I did a couple spots and then I was
introduced to Felipe a guy by the name
of Felipe and Willie Barcena was Latino
Alliance and they would give me Tuesday
and Wednesday nights they gave me that
first Tuesday and Wednesday night they
paid me $40 with a burrito each night Oh
$40 in those days was a lot of [ __ ]
money away $40 for one show so I would
do like to open mics and then get in the
car and shoot down to fill a bedroom and
pick up 40 bucks and that whole week I
didn't go to the store I didn't hang out
at the store I wasn't one of those guys
at all I just wanted an improv spot that
week I worked hard for the 10-minute
showcase I'm not asking you to do it but
do you remember that 10 minutes not even
close really okay I did enough you had a
member not even close
I know that I went off that night I went
down there and I was turning 34 years
old
the night I had to do ten minutes was my
birthday February 19th [ __ ] I wasn't
even here a month I got the time January
29th and it was February 19th and I was
doing 10 minutes from it see on your
birthday my mother died I quit high
school I ran from the law I robbed
people I went you know I got locked up I
got married divorced I had a kid I got a
yang for me because I was basically a
[ __ ] loser and I was 34 [ __ ] his
all with no Direction no direction like
this was all a gamble up to this night
my whole life had been thrown away up to
this night if that's how I had a really
thing about it like if she makes me a
[ __ ] regular what next like it took
me two years 18 months to get on stage I
was so scared
getting onstage feeling while it no
because I feared that name of being a
good comedian yes I feared exactly what
was happening and I feel it I was scared
that my life was gonna change that's
freaky
did you want it to change oh my god in
the worst way in the worst way I wanted
my life to change Lee I couldn't live
like that no more
I was just a [ __ ] disaster I had
become everything my mother didn't want
me to become do you know what that feels
like
she wouldn't like you being a comedian I
would not say that but up to the age of
34 oh I had no [ __ ] direction every
move I had made was wrong how [ __ ]
pathetic is that the move I was scared
to make that was gonna change my life
and I knew it I knew it for 18 months
I knew it if I get on stage something
good might happen when I would go now
nothing that's gonna happen I was so
[ __ ] scared and here I was on my 34th
birthday showcasing the [ __ ] Betsy
Shore it's it's a it was [ __ ] surreal
it was [ __ ] surreal it was like when
my mother died for two or three weeks
when somebody died as you tick it's a
dream for like a month you walk around
and shock your mind is really in shock
you don't really accept it you tell your
friends you're okay but you're walking
around like you got hit my [ __ ] head
you know and here this that that's how I
felt like that night like I'm 34 years
old I've never got it right so this is
going through your head as you're pacing
oh my god to go on stage yes sure
you're not going over your material
you're not no sorry about that no no
holy [ __ ] you're not thinking about your
material you're thinking about why
you're in this situation today I know
people have been up here for 10 years
and they can't become a regular you know
I know people showcase from four or five
times in the way better comics too late
obviously I've seen them [ __ ] they're
way better than I am and they turned up
the phone I seen them there were way
better comedians an hour but she's
there's something she liked about you
and then freaked you out it freaked me
the [ __ ] out I went up on stage I did my
[ __ ] in ten minutes
I got I did eight or nine minutes
because I got off as soon as I saw that
wait I didn't want to go over that light
at all that's so funny I did like my
nine minutes I [ __ ] did what I did on
stage and when I got off she stopped me
again and she goes burn all the four
spots tomorrow you're a regular
congratulations Oh
at any point did you think about the
people who had told you that she was
gonna love you but they were [ __ ] like
yeah yeah with Steve McGrew it was just
a couple certain comedians but Steve
McGrew was the guy that told me when I
was 18 months and she shows little of me
that's why til today me and Steve we
grew as such good friends even though
he's crazy on [ __ ] Twitter mm-hmm
give me some Tony better that's Monday
so now you know you sit there and you
reflect the you alright Joey see you got
into the store after six [ __ ] years
what the [ __ ] are you crying about I
didn't I'm not crying at all I'm telling
you the story of my relationship with
Mitzi show so after she told me I was a
regular she said to me too but I should
dress up like Fidel Castro and bring her
a cigar up on stage she was just Blacky
trying to throw me off now let me
explain something to you people getting
to the Konami store is one thing staying
there is another she'll kick you out she
won't give you spots I didn't say that I
said getting some economy stores one
thing staying there is another tonight I
got past
she passed three other people those
people are long done I see one guy once
a year every day he's drawing pictures
of some [ __ ] now getting there is one
thing staying there is a complete
different other picture all it takes is
her walking him one night you think of a
bombing on stage and it could be that
quick she gets a report that you keep
bombing you get high up there and you
don't you're done but you stopped
getting spots and there's no explanation
and then people end up in the
psychiatric hospital and I'm not kidding
you Lee today was read that see when you
go click Comedy Store now they clean
that up but for years there was remnants
of clamorous that was still earth or
from the cannon
days that was still like [ __ ] up on
blow still waiting for the party I mean
it was [ __ ] sad it was sad so there
were all these remnants of all these
comics that hung out there fears that
Mitzi didn't well that didn't make a
regular they showcase like 13 times for
her and she never made him a regular and
they still hung out up there
and it was sad so again getting to the
comedy store is one thing staying there
is another and he wanted to stay there
now at this time yes now at this time
the word on the street was if you got
two spots a week you were lucky
okay so you had a calling for spots on
Monday so you had seven nights to pick
one most people didn't call him for
Tuesday's because it was black night in
the main room and that meant that the
parking lot would get full and white
people wouldn't come to the Comedy Store
because it was surrounded by black
people this is a true story so on
Tuesday nights comics will call it and
call Wednesday through Saturday or what
happened was this is like I became a but
as soon as I got past at the store a
week later they were posting for a job
as telemarketers so I applied for one of
the jobs of telemarketer in the
afternoon so I would sell cigars in the
morning and then about what I go to
accomplish started in those days it was
me shame attached was that I spoke to
had two nights ago she's a comedian in
Las Vegas the manager was and Mitchell
who ended up buying the club on Wilshire
a family come on Wilshire he was the
telemarketing manager and the other guy
that worked in the room was the guy I
told you from Marie T I see what's he in
those days our job was to call
businesses and give her free tickets
that's it I would call like Larry's body
shop how you doing this is Joey Diaz uh
this is I'm calling you from the clown
restore I wanted you just come on when
was the last time you went on singing a
great entertainment and it's been three
years come sometime bistro let me give
you 20 tickets they they were giving
away tickets that Wow
so I would get a commission and I would
get like $1 if they showed up the other
scam was there was this getting free of
the Comedy Store cards that was the
other scam at The Comedy Store some
somebody came through the door and gave
you that card with your name on it
you got a dollar on Friday so you were
supposed to give those cards out so no
we didn't suppose them holy [ __ ] you
think you deal with some [ __ ] I would
take the [ __ ] cars and take the bus
to you
city huh and I would stand in the middle
and give them to tourists and I would
get sixty [ __ ] people all night my
friend [ __ ] and knowledge Friday and
Sally and I'll ever do that was a line
and without the doorman seeing me I will
go to the back a little line and give
away like 50 tickets probably I'd never
figured out they couldn't figure out how
I was getting 300 hours a week for them
holy [ __ ] but but legitimately I would
take a bus to Universal City in the
afternoon and give away a hundred cards
three days in the world but it's
brilliant just give it the way to people
here you go you're a tourist who's not
gonna take a free ticket yeah and people
would go get me three of them give me
phone and once I'd finish I get back on
the bus I go right over the hill whoever
will let me that car for now and that's
how I did it
top dollar piece here thousand rupees I
didn't [ __ ] around so what I was working
the telemarketing office I would hear
all the complaints upstairs Paul he had
an office upstairs and they loved a guy
off Scott Bay had an office up there so
I could listen to what was going on in
Scott Bay's office well they wouldn't
bitsy would call him when they would
talk about spots so they didn't link
prima donnas they didn't like people
call that Wednesday through Sarah's
habit so she wouldn't give him spots
right off the bat I figured that out
right off the bat you heard them talking
about it that's crazy
so I will call it Monday through Sunday
and the most prestigious smile at the
store those days was Sunday night the
early in seeing the lanit late MC the
early MC was seven to ten and Elaine MC
was tend to close the guys who ran that
MC rule for years were like David
Letterman was a host for her what's the
guy from full house Oh
sagging Bob Saget was a host there
Freddie solar was a host for her
that was a prestigious position and I
wanted that [ __ ] job so the early
host would be Bob Oh Shaq
he's not around please a dear friend I
thought I would see him this week
because he's a comedy store and the late
host would be Freddie solo so I would
show I would always wish I would always
show up on Sundays and she was there and
tried to get on stage or front of her so
she would see a development and I always
was honest with her so like she would
put me in the main room when i bobl I'd
say during the week and one time I
thought I don't want me in the mainland
no more cuz I'm just bothered in there
and that was it she made me go up every
[ __ ] time at the same spot to make me
but you know like she knew you know with
Greg Jackson list anime how to take a
fighter and sculpt them that's what she
was too comedians you know the next
couple weeks or what you guys saw on
Twitter there was a lot of accolades
about her and stuff like that and trust
me is the same people that talk [ __ ]
about of 10 years ago I was there with a
for 10 [ __ ] years straight I dealt
with her on a weekly [ __ ] basis she
called me fat baby she put my name fat
baby on the roster you know I never got
banned from there I did a lot of crazy
[ __ ] even though she figured out you
know I took my dick out my things really
clean she asked me one time on stains
and then I took my dick out of the
Friday night with some chick I took my
dick out like three times like in four
weeks and finally I bumped into and
she's like don't they get dick got Nomar
okay it's quite a workplace oh my god it
was [ __ ] crazy remember from 97 to
about 2006 the asylum was run by the
index we ran that [ __ ] bus
don't take your dick out of it don't
take it they got anymore
but she also made me the house MC now
two nights ago you and I she did on
Sunday nights from 10:00 to close which
for me was a big time honor because I
knew the people who had that position
before I miss Haysom well I first became
a regular at the store
everything else in my life start Lee
eagerly others bought this much I didn't
go anywhere I went to hope I went to
open mics and paid rooms but I just
belong to the copies though it's very
weird nobody ever liked me I never went
to Montreal I never do no festival I
never got invited to anything but that
never meant anything to me you know why
because I was always a regular at the
store
let's see sure lightly I kept that in
the back of my mind for years when I
nobody like me I couldn't even get a
[ __ ] agent wait I couldn't even get
an agent for County no commie agent
whatever [ __ ] sign me but she was
still giving me five spots a week so she
saw something did she manage anybody no
no at that time by the time I got to the
store she was getting older she wasn't
up there every night she was only up
there like two or three nights a week
but she was there every day she was
there in the daytime Monday through
Friday and Saturdays I think I think if
she was there like six days a week but
she knew comic you know like that's
weird that nobody else [ __ ] gave me
any love nobody guys you know when I
tell you adding in nothing people were
getting signed by three arts and CIA and
I see em all around me bro and nobody
people would [ __ ] run from me but she
can't give response but I believed it
the reason why I went to for 18 was
because I believed in comedy like once
she made me a believer I was all in
[ __ ] health [ __ ] everything else it's
all about being a comic which also gave
me a green light to be dangerous I was
dangerous I did blow every night you
know I did promiscuous [ __ ] I did crazy
[ __ ] you know I bet some [ __ ] crazy
people at the Comedy Store
the beginning there were these black
bank robber Santa family that had a
front as a cell phone store and Crenshaw
[ __ ] Compton and I was friends with
them through Eddie Griffin and trust me
I was doing some [ __ ] kinky [ __ ] for
a few years there I'm really [ __ ]
lucky that I never ever ever I him do
you know that okay before I [ __ ] was
the host after the telemarketing
division close and then it's Mitchell
closed they wanted to do something with
me I needed a day job so babo Shack was
the driver five days a week he wanted to
be a writer so he gave me the job two
days a week from Wednesdays and Fridays
I was a driver there it's accomplished
thought you know that right
for who for any and whatever they needed
I would have to go to the hardware store
and pick up material okay I would have
to pick up a tongue sandwich from midsi
Lou at the one Jewish deli and bring it
through a house and drop it off and give
it to the maid that was her favorite
lunch she would get it once a week to
tongue sandwich I would make deposits I
would get changed I would get posters I
would do a thousand things a day I
worked like from 12:00 to 6:00 two days
a week I was also a runner at the store
but then once I started getting bike at
first the first two years I was a
regular at the store how did it travel
and that was done purposely that was
done purposely because I found out that
she had him no she did camera in you do
you insane like she had to know so I
remember when I became a regular that
first week I had calmly worked in
Northern California one of the clubs
with that
Tommy T's and I don't know one of those
it's close to Oakland the selections and
I think was implicit so when I cancelled
it I was opening for somebody I was
featuring for somebody and that first
week she made me a regular they were
like cancel that [ __ ] you don't want to
be gone and then she koala the second
week is she forgettable the [ __ ] you are
right so I focused on the Comedy Store
for [ __ ] my first read like I didn't
leave till money me tonight was when I
started traveling and were you still
doing the telemarketing for them
no the telemarketing division closed
like three months in okay she got into
an argument what to do then that was the
end of that and then [ __ ] I was
I always sold cigars and then when the
cigar thing died down at that time I
sold screws and nuts on the phone and
bolts and there was another company on
high bar and you would have to be there
at 5:00 in the morning so I wouldn't
even sleep I would just go right from
the Comedy Store right there with five
and sell screws and bolts and that's
when I started faxing different Booker's
and I would write my name is Joey Diaz
I'm a regular at The Comedy Store
I managed by such-and-such these over
weeks he got me these little weeks I
have opened and nobody would reply to me
nobody replied I mean nobody reply them
and finally boom one book of replied to
me next thing or another one and every
Monday I would just fax like every day I
would fax a different Booker from that
job that's when I started faxing resumes
every [ __ ] day I would fax ten
resumes at ten different bookish and
admit he tell you this are calling on
the road don't you just follow the right
time I just thought it was the right
time I met your rogue in like probably
98 was when I met Joe 97 and I think the
first road date I did with him was like
98 but at that time Chris McGuire it's a
job full time you know when Joe first
started touring there was Krista McGuire
walking fall and then Chris started
writing more and then me and Joe became
tied again and that that was that story
so and then something else happened in
2000 I forget to mention like 99 I
started traveling heavy when I say heavy
I would disappear for seven months a
shot come back for a month
do a couple auditions have a few
meetings I disappear again and I was
getting fun even funnier on the road
the cloudy store was just carving off
the fat you know I'm saying would you
come in and check in every night how
much yeah if I listen in those days if I
I would if my plane landed at 8:00 I
would call him for a spot
I would have the taxicab who I would
drop me off at the Comedy Store and I
put my luggage in the manager well like
that's the first place I went to when I
got off a plane I couldn't think of not
being there when I became a regular
February 19th
from that time on for maybe two years
straight there wasn't a lot I miss there
I was there seven nights a week at one
point a night I would show up there
because God forbid you caught a fallout
because of my spots were always lately I
was always 12:45 12:15 1:15 in the main
room you know this to go up at 1:15 the
main room on a Saturday night that's
perfect in New York it's a weight and
the same weight city here there's not
that many people there 130 now 40 people
50 people but that's how I learned how
to rock she puts you through that she
puts you through a special regimen like
that's why I'm saying she was like a
great Jackson but you didn't see it I
didn't see it to lay the years I was
always very proud of being a Comedy
Store regular always I've always been
very proud of that fact that's something
you cannot take away from me my name is
on that wall
you could call me a thief you could say
I'm a felon you just say whatever the
[ __ ] you want but that's one thing that
I really really earned was my name on
that [ __ ] law and it meant having my
name on that wall meant everything to me
like that's it
even as if I did something it proved to
me that I did something whether I became
with a listen man I stayed up there as
one of her loyal regulars for ten years
straight I got five spots a week plus
I'd host it and then there's a time in
your life when you have to move on and
you have to decide what you're gonna do
I felt I was there all the time and I
had seen what had happened to people who
were there all its
if you notice now I go to the Comedy
Store every limit it did you know this
side yeah only once or twice a week
maybe there's a reason because I'm
scared to go back to that place where I
was that's a long week at the Comedy
Store
what do you think what happened if you
didn't I just don't know like it's just
the Comedy Store which it's one of those
places that you have to keep in your
life would keep it
distant keep it close but keep it
distance at the same time nothing you
don't take comedy seriously but you've
jumpered priorities now you have a
family yeah and that's probably one of
the reasons why let me give some
shoutouts here
Beto Duran Oscar Lopez ace of so count
Rumple foreskin Tommy this time more
Nicholas Griswold Koppel a beautiful
little doggy you got there
Lenny Gonzales and Bobbie sharing over
there with the kobracast and [ __ ]
Austin Texas [ __ ] this was just I
wanted to do this podcast is attributed
to Mitzi short man I felt that I I just
ordered a tower of my [ __ ] time but I
order more for what she did to me she
was one of those angels I always talked
about in life that come into your life
and get out of your life but they change
a life forever and you never know the
answer you know why they could have this
happened I don't know now I'm a Comedy
Store regular still today 20 years later
I don't know but it was like a family to
me like a family had taken me and like I
took it seriously man wait to me it
meant the world to be a [ __ ] countess
or regular and still play I weren't like
a badge of honor
I was made by [ __ ] Mitzi I wasn't
made by no manager and nobody called me
in nothing no no no
I was you know picked by her at the two
showcases she made me a regular I was a
regular there in less than a month can
you [ __ ] believe that till this day I
still can't get over that how people
here for years even Rogan wasn't a
regular for a while and I mean I know
people are gonna say oh it's just
another day
turn your birthday that has to be fast
the [ __ ] with you at least once it
changed my life forever man
like right there I knew I was staying
right there I knew I had to figure out
what I was gonna do with my life right
there I knew that I was the big leagues
I was a big time I was a small [ __ ]
fry in a big pond so I kept my mouth
shut I watched I listened she made me
follow Paul Mooney for like the year and
that really got me going between Paul
Mooney Dahmer era and AJ Jamal I became
a comedian training behind them they
were like my sparring partners and I
lost every [ __ ] night it was
ridiculous
it was [ __ ] ridiculously I didn't
start getting laughs at the store to
like 2003 1002 was when I started like
really getting the niche of the store I
don't like four years to get the
Michener room how I lasted those four
years I have no [ __ ] idea
I can't imagine loving a place so much
and going there to bomb how was it Bobby
I was learning something new every day
you have no idea what it is to go on at
midnight by 12:15 that stuff Brodie does
that's a different world economy that's
a complete different one is an hour huh
it'll do an hour sometimes yeah it's a
different world of calmly at midnight
tinkle with somebody's head is that at
midnight
what the [ __ ] will you do without at
midnight you know like I would go up
every night at 12:45 ten-to-one wouldn't
[ __ ] us out
vampires there would be eight nine
people in the audience
so my first three
years accommodate I basically performed
five nights a week for eight or nine
people every once in a while they'd be
30 if I was [ __ ] lucky that's and I
mean how much of a big deal we were
talking about going and just being at
the store but would the store have had
the same appeal of mitts he wasn't there
I think she was like a huge part of it
well you don't think Mia's growing up a
lot of you guys don't remember it it was
evening at the improv I've heard of it
but that was a show that was on A&E
early on it was comedians of God stayed
and then they would think [ __ ] uh you
know but Freedman thank you and bud
would sit there with his little monocle
and wave and [ __ ] and it was kind of
cute then you move on in you realize
that that's all [ __ ] those people
don't even talk like that you know
saying Lincoln you you see behind the
curtain and you start getting negative
about it I didn't feel that way with
Mitzi with Mitzi we just talked like was
she the legend that she was she saw
something then a lot of people were
there
Sandra Bernhard the black chick from the
view with the dread-nots one-woman show
upstairs
what tonight Oh whoopee yeah Whoopi
Goldberg the comedy store runs deep guys
this is deep deep deep sometimes you
could not a little high and you look
through the yearbooks and you see like
after us been there like Andy Garcia
Andy Garcia was part of an improv troupe
there on Monday nights I think if I'm
that wrong David Letterman was part of
the improv group on Monday night it's
like the biggest night at the Comedy
Store was Monday nights and Andy Garcia
was part of that like I can't tell you
how many people went through the Comedy
Store at different phases of their lives
you remember what I told you that I
don't know if you're gonna be a stand-up
comic but I know that this is an appoint
or the direction all right yes same
thing with the store
some people got to the store lost and
they went wait a second this isn't what
I wanted to do this is not what I want
to do I do not want to follow [ __ ]
Whoopi Goldberg every night I do not
want to follow crystally I do not want
to follow Richard Pryor this is not what
I thought they just changed careers
really they're following no Lee I'm just
saying that but it's a realization of
what this is right when you get to the
store after you've been in Chicago for
seven eight years fighting for your life
doing open mics and you move out here
and you sign with a manager and you get
to the Comedy Store and you go up there
and you see all these [ __ ] names that
you grew up liking and you grew up
watching that you grew up watching their
specials on Comedy Central that affects
people different ways people go [ __ ] I'm
here this is a bit too scary for me do
you insane like that it didn't it
becomes real when you get to that level
like this isn't the [ __ ] [ __ ]
around level this isn't you and your
buddies in the basement going someday
I'm gonna be a comedian at The Comedy
Store now this is real man now you're
following people now you're in that
[ __ ] mix I told you that four weeks
ago I [ __ ] had a sit one night I'm
the cooler cuz I had to bring up [ __ ]
Martin Lawrence like are you [ __ ]
crazy
like I've been known to comment for 27
years and I've never been blown away and
that night I know Martin I did Martin's
[ __ ] specials on that Network Stars
in 2003 before anybody was doing
stand-up
he Sutton up with that dude Doug and
dinner a stand-up show and I was one of
the convenience I know my words but that
night when I brought him up and I went
to the back and I'm standing there with
row giving [ __ ] Joe and Mickey go and
[ __ ] Kelvin Gastelum
and his [ __ ] Martin Lawrence up on
stage I'm sitting there going this state
this place still blows me back 20 years
later you know that's the magic of the
comedy store it wasn't getting there it
was staying that that's what she taught
me
getting there was one thing staying
there for 20 years
it's a complete other thing and the only
reason why I'm in this way I have a wife
why I have a daughter why I have this
podcast with you is because I'm Richie
sure and what she did for me that night
on my 34th birthday so when I talk about
people and thinking that this was a
catwalk it wasn't a catwalk for anybody
just the fact that I got the showcase
for that woman in my lifetime I was
behind bars guys I went through a
[ __ ] diagnostic I mean you know I've
talked to a prison psychiatrist and Here
I am in front of Mitzi shore showcasing
and then to make it worse I become a
[ __ ] regular I thank her I thank her
forgive me my wife my daughter just
podcast all the things that happened to
me from calmly happened to me because of
the Comedy Store men she sure thank you
very much for listening
tickets for Columbus this week are sold
out but can be I'm coming the third the
fourth and the fifth let the Mexicans
[ __ ] run loose thought thought
thought thought thought thought thought
thought thought thought thought thought
thought thought thought thought there
anyway rest in peace Mitzi sure thank
you very much
forgive me there for showing me the
journey a comedy man thank you for
letting me into your club and thank you
for teaching me how to become a comedian
thank you I want to thank Fuji Sports
listen like I said in the beginning of
the show you're a fat [ __ ] you think I'd
join in jiu-jitsu you gotta buy the
wrong you don't even [ __ ] around go
write the Fuji Sports calm right now
take a look at that line they got a
purple meat it's like a $99 get second
off it's not blue it's not white it's
not black that's a great beginning gate
that's a great year it's comfortable
unless the school wants a white gate
then get yourself a [ __ ] Saporito or
an element and elements a night starting
E it's light it's [ __ ] dorable you
can hang on
[ __ ] gorilla can hang on my [ __ ]
collar and nothing will happen go to
Fuji Sports that time if you're a big
guy here looking for ask cards also Joey
Diaz that net has big rash guards for
you fat [ __ ] also so we got some
[ __ ] rash guards rocking the house
for you also I want to give a shout out
thought out first of all if you like
something from Fuji or the check out
press Church BAM and get 10% off cuz
uncle Joey sent you there alright number
two if you're looking for supplements
you know which way to go
you got a going on it just between the
shroom Tech and a half a brain and the
shroom tech immune right there you hear
you were taking a shroom tech I mean you
went ahead the bronchitis and you
would've been smoking dope with three
hands
I thought tell you [ __ ] up and got
away but anyway alpha brain has a hella
percent money-back guarantee and you
keep the product that's how much belief
they have in their product so well
heinens.com right now impress in church
and get 10% off on your way out and
don't forget to look for all be Marcus's
book go on Amazon type in all be Marcus
I'm a little naming a [ __ ] book right
off and right now but I got a copy at
the house I got a read my rent like the
first day paint is very motivating so go
to or Amazon I think there's something
I'll be more than before be Marcus book
and that's it and that's that this
podcast was from Mitzi shore and just to
let you guys know it's not getting that
it's what you do what the [ __ ] you get
there you understand me
we'll be back Wednesday stay black uncle
Joey loves you have a great week
Fuji sports I love you on it I love you
kick that [ __ ] mule link